good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday
unfortunately
and unfortunately i'm so sorry everyone
you thought
that monday was going to take you down
but jackie and i are here to literally
do the exact opposite
not only do we have a sickening show for
you that's going to sicken the monday
down
we are also sporting our latest merch
collection
the honeymoon merch collection
track suits mugs phone cases we have got
it all
for you so take a look enjoy we'll be
highlighting some of the products
throughout
the next few days different colors yes
we have a lot of different colors we
also have a hat that is the cutest hat
that i've been wearing
um just like around the city and i just
feel so fabulous in it
so we'll be showing you everything i'm
so obsessed with this collection
i'm wearing the teal sweatshirt and
matching sweatpants that have a
100 percent 100
i'm wearing the black obviously that has
down the leg and i just really am so
excited that
this collection is finally here we've
been planning it for so long and i think
the people have known that it's coming
but i don't think they expected it to be
this sickening yeah they've known that
it's coming in we've also reached like
peak hundred percent yeah we've been
saying it
for months but like the amount that we
said it last week was probably more than
we've said it in all the months combined
so it was like
we had to drop it well we were actually
like on one last week like i don't know
if there was something in the water here
at toast studio
but like i was re-watching the episodes
like my god we were just like on another
planet last week like especially just
like with
like the random [ __ ] we were saying like
velma thelma like what
like what was that joke i don't even
remember like you said no of course
no it's because the doo doo doo song
right right right
is scooby doo but we won't go into it
because doo doo's not even here and
because we still don't know is it velma
or thelma and you know what i kind of
like the unknown you know yeah i don't
want to know i don't want to know can it
be both
right like why can't it be about why
can't we why do we have to choose
um so yes this is dropping on wednesday
we will highlight some more products
throughout the week make sure to be
following us on instagram
the morning toast for all the content
all the items and so you don't miss out
on the drop
yeah it's going to be so sickening but
other than that it is still a monday and
like
this one is hitting harder different
worse than ever
it's hitting different like i literally
woke up with a pit in my stomach and i
was like trying to identify the pit and
there were so many sources
just like i just feel so in disarray
you know i just feel like i have so much
to do
mentally physically like actual like
logistically and i'm just
i've been putting it off and i don't
want to do it okay that's interesting
because i actually woke up obviously
like not with a pit but just with like a
kind of like a chip on my shoulder like
the fact that it's monday and like
somehow that's my problem when i
literally like just did monday through
friday
two days ago like how sick how was it
sick
how was this happening again like i just
refused like i actually cannot wrap my
mind around that concept like like i
just did it but whatever
i also woke up within with a can-do
attitude i just feel like
this is our week you know it's the last
week before you go on your retreat so
you're not here next week
next week i'm holding down the ford with
ben and then i'm going to
like this is you know where this is a
dare to be great
situation it is a great week because
it's like the last one before i'm going
on my retreat but maybe because i have
my retreat next week i'm just like this
is a waste of the week
like you're already like yeah let me go
on my retreat you know i'm just waiting
and by the way i don't know if i've
updated everyone but i booked my retreat
it is happening i will keep you all
posted obviously i'll be vlogging
for the patreon and i'm really excited
i'm excited to just
cross it off my list you know and we're
at this itch where you ended up is like
a good facility like i feel very
comfortable sending you off there
not wondering like if you're getting
mauled by a bear in the woods
yeah so i feel really good about it and
i'll keep you all abreast of course
because you guys are on this journey
with me like as much as anyone
and i really appreciate everyone's
support and we're gonna we're gonna be
in this together though i will truly be
doing it alone
and i haven't had like a solitary
experience like that in so long
i feel like i'm gonna go back to like
high school version me it's like oh my
god how do i make friends like how do i
talk to new people
are you like is that something that
happens at the retreat like you make
friends
i think you get like in groups and so
other people will probably be alone like
some people probably be like with
friends or something so it's gonna be
it's gonna be like high school
personally challenging well if you just
bring your kindle like you're fine yeah
no that's
i i'm not worried about that but i do
feel like they'll be like icebreakers
you know two truths and a lie
let's practice the truths and a lie is
my [ __ ] cross to bear it's the
hardest [ __ ] icebreaker
because like i think it's harder to come
up with the truth like
who cares like i wouldn't even know what
to say so let's come up with yours
oh my i know i literally can't okay oh
okay so the lie is obviously
um i'm not a natural redhead like you
should say that because like that's dumb
and people probably think you're not a
natural redhead which you are
so say that and then for your truths um
i have to speak my truth no i know it's
so important and it's my truth
no one else no one else is um so like
what's like a crazy thing you've like
done
like nothing like you're so boring like
no like you don't have like some people
like when they were babies they were
born with three legs like
some people have like crazy like an
extra toe like you don't have anything
like that
yeah yeah no i don't know that's why i
literally hate this game and i
it's so hard i'm so sorry that i brought
it up like yeah now i have to prolong
like it's worse that i have to play it
no but if we come up with them now it's
not enough that i have to play it there
but like to bring it into my personal
ideas
but i'm just trying to prepare you for
what could be like a painful icebreaker
i know i just sort of like panic and i'm
like i'm allergic to bees
oh yeah yeah yeah am i i don't know yeah
you are you are
not really i had a bad experience once
but like since then thank you i'm sorry
if you get sung by a bee and then have
to go to the hospital like you are
allergic but then like later in life i
got stung by b and i was fine
so me i think my working theory is that
the hospital
experience it wasn't a b it was a
different
big ass oh no i've been stung by a wasp
do you know that tech talk sound no the
fact that you like aren't on tick tock
as much as i am is so upsetting
because like margot would have
understood my but why don't you explain
it to us because i think a lot like
that's the thing about tic toc sounds
you can't explain that i feel like you
do a good job of explaining them and
then like i'm in on the joke and i
literally will like
say tic toc lines that i've never even
seen i've been stung by a wasp
i actually i can't explain that one like
i don't know the origins it sounds
pretty self-explanatory
so funny yeah also speaking of tick tock
we um went to dinner last night with dom
roberts we finally got to meet dom and
kenzie
and we were talking about tic tac and i
looked at my screen time last week you
guys
see someone needs an someone needs a
[ __ ] wellness retreat okay so
unplugged wellness retreat but like for
me like my idea of wellness is like
laying in bed scrolling on tick tock
but so last week i spent over the course
of the entire week
24 hours on tic tac which is literally
an entire day it was actually 25 hours
so
i'm just kind of like dealing with that
you know like you should
i don't know how to internalize the fact
that i lost a whole day of my life of
your week
in life yeah imagine how many days of
your life you've lost
do i know probably a hundred
no well no you've only been tick-tock
for like over a year but if you're
losing one day a week
of 52 days you know it's like really
crazy you guys so
i'm just kind of like working through
that and trying to like
like digest and internalize it and like
what do i do with that piece of
information because
you need to do something no i know it's
been like shaking me in my core like
ever since i found that out
good maybe you set like a screen time
limit on tick tock because even though
you'll go over it obviously like
it'll be there like nagging you and
maybe you'll just be more conscious of
it
no that's like an alarm like i'll just
use it you should go on a retreat where
you have to like turn in your cell phone
no i just like need to the thing is it's
like so or
or you know what some people consider it
24 hours spent on doing my job like
it is my job to be kept depressed to all
the treasures
it's not going to cut i hear what you're
saying and i think that that's like a
good
uh rationale for you know a lot of our
technology addiction and like tv
but that's a step too far but that's the
thing i'm like not watching tv anymore
because i'm literally sitting in bed
watching tick tock
what about a challenge like
we'll hold you accountable here at the
toast and we will give you
three hours a day okay let me see what i
did i mean yesterday i was like hungover
so
i probably had more than average three
times no that's still almost i'm sorry
i was wrong one hour a day oh you get
one hour
so yesterday and then we're gonna look
at your week
next week i won't be here excited okay
yesterday i had two hours that's not bad
no saturday two hours
it's pretty much two hours a day i guess
that makes sense two times seven oh no
maybe i just had like a really bad week
last week apparently you were on one
oh i mean on monday of last week i had
four hours so like i think we should try
and get you to an hour a day
yeah i think so too and we'll follow up
next week last week i
i had anything to turn on the thing that
says like you're approaching your time
limit
add limit yeah how long should i do one
hour
hour and a half no do an hour you might
go over it doesn't like lock you out but
that way you're
you're trying to get on the right but
then by the way today i'm already at
20 minutes you know you have 40 minutes
left spend them wisely
that is so little now you won't be like
frivolously like looking through tick
tock
but they make me happy like i don't know
why there's like a stigma around screen
time when like i'm literally at my
happiest like scrolling tick tock
mindlessly because it's so unproductive
and you watch the whole
day of your life like looking at other
people probably inevitably comparing
yourself to this person that person like
it does it doesn't
yeah yeah no once in a while you see a
tick tock that's like uplifting but most
of the time it's like
detrimental to mental you know like
because i'm like so
like much prettier than everyone on tick
tock it's like actually not fair of me
to even like be on tech talk because i'm
like so much prettier and skinnier than
everyone
yeah and younger and younger and like
just funnier and like it's sad for
everyone else you know
i should have take talk to help other
people's mental health because like
they're probably comparing themselves to
me and it's like oh my god like i'll
never be as stunning
beautiful and smart as this girl like
maybe maybe for the
the betterment of my generation i should
just take a step back
whatever it takes whatever it takes
whatever it takes
i know i can make it through what song
is that it's a theme
song from yes
i'm gonna need a minute okay i'm gonna
give you a clip it's like a
california-based show
i don't know where this is
it's at one point in our childhood we
were banned from watching it because it
was like a little inappropriate
oh degrassi yeah um canada
yeah no it's canada right no i was just
thinking i thought it was maybe going to
be like 90210 or like
right full house
um okay also if anybody wants to do the
tick tock challenge with claudia like
please yeah free to join share your
screen times we're getting to an hour a
day on the talk
an hour a day but like that's so hard
sometimes self-care looks like hard work
literally literally okay
good um also i just wanted to share like
an experience um that i had over the
weekend because you know
i feel like i come on here a lot and
like talk [ __ ] about zara and i stand by
literally everything i've ever said
about sarah like
the website is an atrocity like just
like make it
make it easy for us like make it work
but
i went to sarah on saturday and i don't
even want to say it because i don't want
everyone to go to hour and then like
we'll all be wearing the same things but
like
the zara summer collection like is here
and it might be their most sickening yet
like i literally picked up like 15
things the dressing rooms are closed
because of cobia so i just like picked
up a bunch of things and i'm like i'll
just return whatever i don't wear
did not return one single thing like so
sickening and they've really gotten
better with their sizing inclusivity and
i just like wanted to give a shout out
because like i'm always talking [ __ ]
about sarah but
they did that like summer 2021 like they
[ __ ] did that sweet okay i might go i
literally need to shop for new clothes i
know and like i literally got a whole
new wardrobe in 10 minutes like i just
like was picking [ __ ] up and i'm like
half of this won't fit but i will come
back and return it and it's like kind of
like added like
i think it's really contributing to my
good attitude like on this monday
because i'm like okay like we're
stepping into spring like i have a hot
fire wardrobe you're prepared
like not prepared fully but like i will
be going back and i saw a tick tock see
this is why i need to
i saw tick tock that the most underrated
um zara in all of manhattan is the
hudson yards one
because hudson yards is a luxury mall so
people go there not for sarah they go
for like
the neiman marcus even though i'm out of
business um and because it's the biggest
went out of business yeah like that
whole thing is going out of business
the neiman marcus said hudson arts
closed i'm almost 100 did you not know
that
i don't know maybe i did but i don't
know i feel like you told me i didn't
absorb it no but i heard neiman marcus
was like
filing for bankruptcy but that doesn't
mean that they closed which is the navy
market was so nice which is really
confusing
okay neiman marcus hudson yards
permanently closed
wow um yeah it was really sad but
because like most people don't go to
zara
don't go to hudson yards for sarah and
it's also the biggest they have like
literally
every size every item it's like the most
in stock zara in all of manhattan
so that's a little kept secret that i
just blew up and that pulled up on tick
tock so
maybe i'll do that this week sweet
sounds fun yeah
um other than that i need to get to zara
and now i know
and zara zara trends on the day
yeah right mm-hmm cool cool cool
should we get into everything yeah we
got the fast five we got um
real housewives of atlanta recap so i
just feel like without further ado
yeah without further ado it's time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and i'm very excited because today's
episode is brought to you by public
goods and i've been using their products
for like a few weeks now and i've just
been waiting
to come into the studio and this piece
of paper is on my
desktop because i just did not expect to
like
find my new brand do you know what i
mean like everything okay so public
today's episode is brought to you by
public goods the one-stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials
made from clean ingredients at an
affordable price everything from coffee
to toilet paper to shampoo and pet food
public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer
so there's so many benefits to um public
goods of course like being a sustainable
brand and being able to shop for
everything in one place but like
the products sickening the all-purpose
cleaner the dish soap and then the hand
soap like i just didn't expect to like
find my favorite
new three products you know 100 smells
so good
and the aesthetic like we talk about the
aesthetic
yeah like who am i nobella like
literally like all the bottles of
packaging it's like so simple and
elegant it's like literally like
kardashian like minimalist
it's just like the most sickening bread
and i just didn't see that for myself
this year
yeah no it's really exciting i used a
surface cleaner last night to
clean up a little bit of bruno's duty
and it was amazing
masks the smell but also doesn't have
like an annoying pungent ass smell
no not chemically either everything
about it is so subtle and sickening
no i agree like when i hosted you out on
friday which was one of the most
overwhelming things i've ever done like
we'll never be hosting again
i use the cleaner on everything like it
just and also it added like a nice aroma
to my home i'm like
yes i have a clean home even though like
i don't but like you know the
the public good scent made it seem like
i did um so rather than buying from a
bunch of single product brands
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place
with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic
public goods talks public goods searches
the globe to find clean healthy
eco-friendly and innovative products
they ethically source and obsessively
develop each of their products to be
free of unhealthy ingredients
harmful additives comet and it's still
common on drug and grocery store shelves
they are committed to making their
products healthy and safe for humans
animals and the environment
yes when i was getting ready for shabbat
i was getting the hummus out and i had
this huge jug of hummus and it literally
slipped out of my hands
fell upside down and got all over my
kitchen floor and like i literally
ushered theo out of the kitchen i was so
stressed
and i cleaned it up and i sprayed
the purpose all-purpose cleaner to like
clean up the smell of hummus
and then i let the o back in because
like it's not harmful on pets
love to see it um we got an awesome deal
for you guys if you want to get 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase they are so
confident that you will absolutely love
their products and come back again and
again and again
they're giving you 15 to spend on your
first purchase plus right now
you can receive your choice of either a
free pack of bamboo straws or reusable
food storage wraps with your order
you have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com toast
or use the code toast to check out
that's p u b l i c
g o o d s dot com forward slash toast
to receive 15 off your first order check
it out
check it out everything of the sort
totally
okay first story dmx the rapper and
actor
dies at the age of 50. his family has
announced in a statement
they said we are deeply saddened to
announce today that our loved one dmx
birth name of earl simmons
passed away at 50 years old at white
plains hospital with his family by his
side
after being placed on life support for
the past few days earl was a warrior who
fought till the very end he loved his
family with all of his heart and we
cherished the times we spent with him
it's really sad um he'd been on life
support for like a week right
yeah because like in the beginning of
the week we reported on it yeah we
reported on it last week
um it's so sad and all weekend there
have been like
tributes coming out like videos that are
going viral yeah i saw that one
everyone keeps tagging me in this tweet
about which is really crazy
i know um and i guess like what's so
what i've like kind of gathered from all
of people's tributes is like how
influential like in the music space he
was like i think he was a little bit
before our time
um but it's been made very clear like in
the hip hop space like his legacy like
lives on
so i'm just really sad for his family
and i hope that they're all doing okay
yes hope everyone is doing okay really
sad i saw um they're
considering doing like a uh memorial in
yonkers for him oh no it would be
amazing
yeah yeah so
just really sad and amazing legacy to
see
like everyone sharing also i feel like
all weekend my whole
timeline was flooded with like dmx
tributes and princeville up
yes um but the big question has been
answered prince harry
will be going to his funeral megan will
be staying home
under doctor's orders because of her
pregnancy which is really quickly
while you brought up dmx and prince
philip can we talk about kerry
washington for a second
yeah kerry washington got like canceled
over the weekend because she like
tweeted something out that was like not
offensive but just like kind of weird
um she's like what'd she say she said
uh can't you just imagine what dmx and
prince philip are talking about at the
pearly gates right now
like such a beautiful like thinking of
both of them and
she deleted it after like getting
annihilated on twitter
and i was trying to like see why people
like were so upset about it
because it to me it wasn't offensive it
was just like a cringy losery thing to
say like
that's just like a weird thought like
they don't know each other they're
definitely not even together and like
some people are like
prince phillips and hill like people are
so annoying so i didn't really
understand why she got canceled but like
if anything i would just be like
embarrassed like because that was like a
lame tweet
yeah i mean that's all it is at least
for me
i don't think there's anything really
offensive about it just like a weird
thing
just like a weird thought to have yeah
and then also share
but oh and share yeah i think c-h-e-r
i'm like oh what did she tweet oh she's
always tweeting she's always getting no
um a weird thought to have for sure i
don't know that it's grounds for
cancelling but you know
there's it's lawlessness it's
lawlessness
yeah so yes i did see that because you
showed it to me
because i was just like so confused i'm
like i'm not missing something like from
this tweet like
that's it just like cringy yeah
but sorry back to prince harry well now
prince harry has arrived in the uk two
days after
um prince philip's death and he will be
attending the funeral
i'm glad sans megan how far along is
megan
i don't know i'm not it doesn't say
yeah cause like i'm sure she does not
want to go and the pregnancy is like a
fabulous experience yeah
it's a fabulous excuse it would be
really awkward i think it's awkward that
harry's going it's literally
a month after this whole oprah interview
like and you you you made your bed
laying it
no i completely agree like i think it's
weird like this will be the first time
they're seeing each other i think in
over a year also because of covet it's
like his first time going back to
since mexico the uk and i if i like just
see stay home no it's weird like
especially because i think it's going to
be like a super small covenant
so if he had stayed in california like
it wouldn't have been
such a big deal because you could say
covet you know yeah i just like don't
understand
harry like completely because like he
did go
on this interview and like kind of you
know air his family's dirty laundry
so like which do you like your family or
do you not like your family like i'm
confused because if you love your family
like you even if like they've wronged
you
you don't go on tv and like you know
air your dirty laundry yeah so i'm just
confused i'm glad he's going because
like that's the type of thing you can't
take back like
if you make a decision in anger and like
like a tell-all interview is also the
sort of thing you can't take back
yeah no no no i know so it's done i'm
just
um i'm really confused at this point but
but
megan not going um i'm not confused by
like don't go
yeah like that tracks she's being
consistent harry's not being consistent
100
which is it like which is it yeah you
can't have it both ways
yeah so and it's just gonna be like
literally awkward like
so everyone knows their business like we
know that him and william aren't on good
terms and now we know kate was the one
who made megan cry like
we like we know too much he just like
blew this [ __ ] up and i was like going
back like hey guys i'm back
and also everybody's grieving like it's
just not about him for like one second
and now he has to come and make it about
him yeah
you know like i'm sure in prince
philip's final days like this was a a
very big story
yeah and i'm not saying that he should
or shouldn't go
i think he should go i
it's a tough situation but i do think he
should go
yes in the sense because like it is
something like that something
again that you can't take back and
you'll regret and it's like
at a certain point like family and death
like that conquers all you know like you
just are there for your family
and this is one of those situations i
think so
i think him going is the right decision
but it does
make all this news you know which i just
think like the royal family is just like
over the news for now they could like
use a little break
and they also like they have a lot of
healing to do as a family right
and maybe this is when they'll do it but
like there's other there's
other things going on like it's a
celebration of of prince philip's life
like
they'll heal another time because like
any other time
yeah you know yeah no it's um
it's a tough spot like i don't know
what's the right thing but i do think he
should go to the funeral i'm glad he is
going and i don't think megan should go
and i'm glad she's not going and i'm
sure she's glad to not be going
yeah even though it actually doesn't
track
because like in the interview when they
were in the chicken coop she was like no
like we talked to that we spoke to gran
you know last week when you know philip
got sick mm-hmm
so according to them like they've been
on good terms with the ground
with the grandparents and they went out
of their way to tell open with
but that was all pre-tell-all no but
they after the tell-all they went out of
their way to say the person who made the
comment about archie's skin color was
not gran or grandpa right so it's like
they've kind of been protecting
in their own way yes but in doing the
tell-all
they inadvertently like have
you know you can't protect somebody have
tried like to
ruin like their life's work like this
was the q like the royal
being royals being the king and queen
are not
king sorry queen con prince prince
is their life's work and harry and megan
have made that
much more challenging yeah i mean but
they also
right like they they what i gathered
from their interview was that like they
did not want to insult
or like tarnish the name of philip or
grad like they kind of
protected them in the interview whether
they were actually
good to them or not like it that was
like clearly something that was
important to to harry
but it's kind of like a one of them is
all of them you know like 100
so it doesn't even yeah 100 yeah
so we shall see we shall see i just
can imagine the tension like and you
know like i
i can't imagine that harry thought he'd
be seeing his family so soon after the
interview but like
that's what happens life happens death
happens and now we're all in a room
together
yeah let's talk about it maybe i'll make
a maybe it will be maybe it'll be
prince phillips final gift to the family
everyone's coming together
and that would be a great episode of the
crown like we're just kind of like his
death brings everyone together they all
apologize they love each other
harry and megan move back resume their
royal duties
and then megan can like but for me like
what i was so upset about this whole
thing is like
of course there's so many things i could
be annoyed at but like what i was
annoyed at is the fact that like
meghan markle like could have been an
integral part
of the royal family if they had let her
she's so charismatic
she's you know a sign of progress for
the royal family like the potential
there that we never got like that
was what was so upsetting in terms of
like representation and so
if we could if there's any possibility
like that she could like be that i'm
sure she does not want to but like
i would just love that i know i don't
think there's i hear what you're saying
i know that ship has sailed completely
it's not happening i know but they will
have to all figure out how
to forward forward and if they want to
like stay in touch
so this could be step one for all of
that it could
we'll keep you abreast even though it's
not like we're gonna be
in those rooms so we just have to go off
like tabloid reports which are
so false i don't know from the crown i
know like the crown is fiction whatever
from the crown it kind of
like makes it seem like sometimes more
often than not like some of the tabloid
rumors are like founded on truth
or maybe the crown only addresses the
ones that are true oh that's possible
yeah
the ones that i mean there's so many
yeah you know like every day it's
something different
yeah okay ready for our next story
little sports news
a little sports news yeah are you ready
for a little sports news because the
master's tournament
chicken history has been made as hideki
matsuyama
makes history he wins the 2021 masters
tournament you watched it
because ben watched it and like we were
so just like dead yesterday that i just
let him put on whatever he wanted
and you know i actually quite enjoyed it
um
matsuyama was like in the lead the whole
time so like he obviously was gonna win
yeah um and ben was explaining how it's
like such a big deal
so i'm so happy for him and he was a
cutie
and it was actually like an enjoyable
thing to watch this cutie win
maybe the biggest cutie man and like ben
said like part of the huge honor of
winning the masters is like
the next year there's a huge dinner with
all the former winners
and the person who won the year before
like gets to pick the meal choice
so now everyone's like guessing what
matsuyama's gonna pick and like now
this year because the winner from last
year was dustin paulina gretzky's
boyfriend johnson justin johnson he
chose uh chicken sandwiches
oh yeah you said you didn't win no i
know i would have loved that meal i bet
it's so good
that's such a fun fact like fun like um
tradition 100 yeah that's really cool i
feel like golf is super calming to watch
you know yeah
like it was like a little borderline
boring yeah yeah but it's not like
no it's not like crazy like you look
away you're gonna miss anything yeah and
they actually like
do a really good job of um airing it
because
they like show they don't follow one
person at the same time like show
everyone at different holes it's like
actually
i had a respect for the master they got
a good thing going on yeah they got a
really good thing going on
very very cool yeah so i'm happy for him
i can't wait to hear what he chooses for
the meal like i'm
literally like i can't think about
anything else i'm so excited like i hope
it's good
um and um he's making japan proud so we
love that
if you won the masters what would you
choose is your meal oh that's a
really good question um
[Music]
okay for an appetizer we would all be
having
chicken fingers and fries like but like
in app in
in appetizer form you know a toothpick
in it okay okay
and then for the entree we are having
um oh my god i'm like overwhelmed right
now hold on
um let me just think like what are my
favorite foods like we're having like
it's pasta night you know like italian
like
pasta whatever you want like and you
don't care that the foods like don't
really make sense
together do i look like a girl okay and
then for
um dessert we're having a chipwich
oh cute good humor brand like with the
chocolate chips on the outside oh that's
really cute
that sounds good i think i would have
seraphina come in and get her and cater
the affair the affair
yeah like pizzas to start yeah but then
for dessert
i've been really enjoying dessert lately
and like seraphina we went to last night
we took tom and kenzie's
seraphina virginity um is not known for
their desserts like i literally
never get them no no they have a
tiramisu which i don't even like that
like some people like but they are not
like dessert friendly yeah maybe just
like some delicious gelato or like the
masters butter cake have you ever had it
yes
yeah okay you guys you want me to win
masters yeah let's go
root for me well like a time vote for us
are you ready for our next story i mean
i'm going to take a bite of my granola
bar but yeah
okay so while you're taking a bite um
i'm gonna let you know that driver's
license singer olivia rodrigo got a
parking ticket
that's really funny she said driving
isn't all fun and games
olivia rodrigo is quickly learning the
ups and downs of having a driver's
license on sunday the 18 year old singer
whose ballad driver's license became a
mega hit revealed that she ran into a
little trouble
while driving with her driver's license
in a snapchat chair to her instagram
story she shared that she received a
parking violation from the city of la
showing a photo of the ticket she said
damn this driving [ __ ] isn't all fun
and games i mean and that's why i don't
drive
that is why i love that this is news you
know
it's just like because she has a song
called driver's license right
and she got a ticket and i feel like
it's a really good lesson for all the
kids
out there like driving is not all fun
and games well i was actually just
having this conversation with them
because he's like i've never been in an
accident
and i have obviously you remember you
made me get into an accident when you
were singing shower bye bye
you were just like being such a
distracted like front seat driver
i think i was like making the vibes good
you were snapchatting yourself listening
to becky g's shower which is such a good
song
yeah can you blame me i know and you
know it's such a good song like the car
crash didn't even ruin it it's such a
good song it inspired a segment on this
show yeah that's true
um but so ben was like bragging that
he'd never gone to an accident like i
didn't get into an accident i just
sideswiped some old lady's car it was
just like a little dink
and she was like so cool about it like i
was ready to like swap insurance and
like have to like you know call the
police
and she literally was like a sign and
got in her car and drove away
um but i've never gotten a ticket ben
has gotten like
maybe a thousand like you know he
actually one point like got his license
suspended for like having so many points
that's so crazy so um have you well you
don't drive but
right so i can't even ask you that
question but one day i feel like my time
is coming
yeah we've been talking about getting a
car yeah and that would be really
exciting
for me to be driven by you i know and
also if you're
if you're looking for some content i
talked jackie how to drive over the
summer in upstate new york
um and there's a patreon vlog about it
at patreon.com morning toast
so much anxiety oh did you have
something to say
um no i was just gonna get into our
fifth and final story the final
story if i can just like let everyone
know about babble i would
really yes i think everyone needs to
know about babel therefore you you may
have the floor
for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point of our
academic careers
yes do not ask me to speak any other
language
i can't speak hebrew anymore i can't
speak spanish now thanks to babel the
number one selling language learning app
there's an addictively fun and easy way
to learn a new language
whether you'll be traveling abroad
connecting in a deeper way with family
or you just have some free time
babo teaches you bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world
so i chose babel to like really um touch
up on my hebrew because
i haven't learned hebrew in so long and
i'm going to israel in june so like i
just like don't want to be like
so american you know and like i feel
like it's really frowned upon in other
countries like
to not even know like the slightest bit
of the yeah and you're so close so you
might as well go all the way with babel
and like if i'm spending so much screen
time on my phone like i might as well be
making an educational yeah
so babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go so you can literally take it on
the subway i do it when i'm in the back
of a car like literally whatever
um their courses are designed with
practical real world conversations in
mind
things you'll get to use in everyday
life other language apps learning
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german
plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation
and accent start your new language
learning journey today with babble
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code
tmt that's babb el.com
the code is tmt for an extra three
months free
babble language for life love it okay
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story
is it the five and finals
yeah yeah okay henry cavill cavill
yeah goes instagram official with his
new beautiful and brilliant girlfriend
natalie viscuso and i know claudia is
like
why i saw the picture you saw the
picture he said this is me looking qui
well they they took a stroll together
they were spotted on a stroll
and then he posted to his instagram
saying oh sang
oh god what'd you do i just swiped hold
on saying i think maybe i haven't
memorized i saw that they were
photographed together and like literally
nobody could figure out who this girl
was okay well
he then he posted a picture of the two
of them saying this is me looking
quietly confident
shortly before my beautiful and
brilliant love destroys me at chess and
it's like a picture of them playing
chess
but eagle-eyed pop culture enthusiasts
might
recognize her from a 2005 episode of
mtv's my super sweet 16.
her milestone birthday was featured on
season one of the hit series after she
moved to san diego
from moswell roswell new mexico
okay so now she um is the vice president
of tv and digital studios at legendary
entertainment
but she was on my super sweet 16 and i
feel as though that's something that we
all need to know
okay i'm literally floored by this
recognition like floored first of all
second of all
there is a tick tock trend of like if
you were on my sweet 16 super sweet 16
like make a tick tock do at this and
like tell us where you landed and like
literally every single one of them was
like the car my dad got me got
repossessed like we had to move out of
our house like because it was these
people like spending so fervously on a
16 year old birthday party like you know
that their finances were not
yeah they're not like financially
prudent so i would love to hear like a
little bit about her journey on the show
i wonder if we'll get like any sort of
interview with her
and remind me who henry cavilis justice
league
superman was he supposed to be jamie
dornan or that's like the other guy i
always get them confused
oh you was supposed to be jamie dornan
like the other guy
henry something why why not cavil
i don't know like someone someone named
henry dropped out of 50 shades and gave
it to jamie dornan who i thought was
like so unqualified for the role
i mean that's why i never watched a
franchise i just always felt like it was
a huge casting mistake when that guy
dropped out
henry um okay well henry cavill is
superman and he looks like superman
yeah and i feel like he could have been
the one and is he from sons of anarchy
is he i don't know like these henry's i
actually cannot okay i'm gonna read what
he's in
i don't know if it's gonna mean anything
to you man of steel the witcher batman
vs superman justice league and nola
holmes mission impossible
the man from uncle i like the man from
auntie
zack snyder's justice league the tudors
everyone's been telling me to watch the
tutors and now i think this might be the
push that i need
okay hold on henry cavill was supposed
to be
in 50 shades of grey but he's not who i
thought he was
um charlie oh yeah
by the way they literally don't even
have the same name i don't know why i
get them you know don't put that [ __ ] in
my head
no that guy's hot the blonde guy he's
kingsman
is he this guy he's from sons of anarchy
never mind he's so handsome
i get him confused with henry cavill but
actually henry cavill looks like matt
bomber bowmer you're just like you're
putting stuff into my head that i don't
need
there's just like so many like sexy men
like i actually just cannot keep
track of them but now i know who henry
cavill is i've never seen like
any superhero movies so like people in
that genre like just go way above my
my head i agree and he's not in the
kingsman so i'm just gonna take that
back
i don't know who that guy is when is the
kingsman sequel coming out
the tree quill i don't know but wait now
i need to find out who the guy i'm
thinking of from the kingsmen because i
feel like it's gonna
collin first it's gonna blow the lid off
this taran edge no no no no no
he's a supporting man the king's men
cast
oh my god i love the kingsman okay
hold on i'll just be able to drink this
guy i'll just be drinking for my hundred
this bug available wednesday at
shotmorningtoast.com he plays a guy
named charlie
in the movies
he's like that guy who's with the girl
why are you showing me the most tiny
picture like how am i supposed to see
okay that is like the most random guy no
but he's the guy that's with the girl
no um this episode is called those guys
that are with the girls like
there's just so like honestly there's so
many famous people now like i actually
cannot keep track and i feel like i know
most of them but with the birth of tick
tock and like all these digital famous
people and now that and there's all
these
streaming platforms there's so much
content there's so many famous people i
agree so like
forgive me for getting my henries and
charlie's confused like it's just a
i'm a victim of circumstance like i can
only keep up i and i know a lot but like
this is like kind of crazy yeah i think
you're making we are making it like
harder than it means to me like it's
just henry and his my super sweet 16
girlfriend
oh right okay okay focus on when i first
saw the picture like the picture was
like this really serious chess picture i
thought he was
dating anna taylor joy yeah who is anna
taylor joy dating
i don't know she's like so eligible like
remember how like two years ago during
award season like
anna jarmus was like the most eligible
bachelorette in hollywood and then like
ben affleck got her
and now it's like who is going to get
anna taylor joy because she's like the
most eligible girl of awards season like
e news like dies for her you know yeah
as they should yeah
i just wonder who who the lucky person
will be yeah
um okay so let's dive into our tv recap
segment which is the real housewives of
atlanta which was on last night which
was so incredibly boring
brought to you by legacy box an
effortless way to have your
tapes films and photos digitally
preserved to a modern format so they're
safe
for generations i get dms like literally
almost every day like what was the
company who does the
vcr pay attention please
um so if you have moments that you want
to like um preserve we have
over the years like collected so many of
our home tapes and like we bought all
these like weird things on bestbuy.com
to like
transfer it it never worked and legacy
box was the answer to all of our
questions
it's so easy you can reclaim all the
priceless footage that you haven't been
able to see in years
the service from legacy box is so simple
use their kit to safely send the moments
you want preserved whether it's vhs's
cds anything
their team will create a digital archive
by hand then you'll receive your new
copies either stored on the cloud a
thumb drive a dvd
along with all the original media you
sent them so with their tracking system
you can follow every step of the process
so you always know your originals are
being taken care of
legacy recently surpassed a million
customers that's a million people
celebrating milestones
legacy box is offering 50 off to our
listeners so you can get started
preserving the moments that have stood
out in your life today
do not waste this opportunity there's
limited supplies legacy box like will
change your life it's the best gift
for a mom or a grandma or someone who
just like appreciates sentimentality
um so go to legacybox.com toast
to join more than a million other
families who have used legacy box for
just a fraction of the regular price
take advantage of 50 off today and send
in your legacy box whenever you're ready
go to legacy box dot com slash toast and
again that's
50 off while supplies last so don't miss
out legacybox.com
toast love it okay the real housewives
of atlanta was like
so boring but to me the most interesting
part of the episode was like seeing all
the food at blaze steakhouse like
gotta go there for a meal it looked so
good it looked so good yeah the episode
was boring all this drama
with the prophet like i was so confused
and
i didn't agree with anyone like i kind
of agreed with drew no but then
after speaking to prophet and
if toya and him really don't have a
romantic relationship but even if they
do
but i don't even think he would lie like
if if they did have a relationship she
wouldn't have called him up
and had like a man of the faith lie
on t like i just don't think so no but
see like how do we have such two
opposite stories
drew heard literally he broke up with
his fiancee left his baby
to be with toya they're in a committed
relationship toya
story is like i literally barely know
this man like no like that she like
is taking his seminar but like he was
engaged three years ago and that's just
so like how do we have such two like
literary polar opposite stories i don't
know someone's lying
yeah but but i kind of believe drew but
even if drew's telling the truth like
it's none of her business it's the same
thing as like all this stuff with bolo
like
it's no actually i normally would agree
with you but the only reason i was kind
of taking drew's side because let's say
it's all
completely true and like the
prophet and his family are like a part
of drew's family which is what she's
been saying like
drew has every right to be mad that like
she introduced the prophet to her friend
and like now he left his fiance
for the friend when like drew is like
family with them like i can see if what
everything drew is saying is true why
she would be upset and like how nobody
understands that like confused me
like if if she really broke up a family
if toya broke up a family
who was so close with drew like
allegedly for years you know
yeah i just but that's assuming
everything drew is saying about the
relationship
with the people so confusing and i also
like really don't care so i'm like
confused and i'm trying to care and i
don't
i wanted more of the lipo like i wanted
more clarity i'm not because
no i don't no because she brought it up
and she said she's gotten it twice and
she's getting it again you don't lie
half lie about liposuction yeah she was
the one who brought the word to the
table and then
i i'm sure she was like maybe planning
on it maybe it just or she's doing it
but
i thought she was being super honest and
i also feel like she was really humbling
herself at that dinner and just being
like yeah i'm sorry and eating she
felt really bad she's apologized so many
times like clearly it was one of those
nights where you just
you act it out things fall apart you
know i completely and you just behave in
a way that you personally don't agree
with and i
and she's doing everything right in the
way she's apologizing and like everyone
needs to move on
i completely agree like because i love
marlow and like in new orleans i'm like
what are you doing like
putting yourself in the center of all
this like acting insane in front of big
frida like relax
um but the way she like literally ate
[ __ ] and like humbled herself and like
apologized to every single person like
multiple times brought gifts
oh buying porsche's sheets she doesn't
want the discount like she's obviously
trying really hard yeah so i'm like so
glad because like as a marlo stan like i
really have respect for that um
and in no way did i think she was lying
about the liposuction like shamia was
just going so hard for her when like
some a friend of a friend saw you at the
doctor's office like maybe she was
having a consultation like yeah
and also like people's medical doings
like are personal you know like leave
them alone
and marlo brought it up right she's
definitely not lying no i don't think
she's lying
it was just all very weird the whole
episode was just weird and i just didn't
care and
also the season finale is next week when
like literally nothing has happened
except for the bolo stuff
yeah i think they thought that that
would like carry through the season i
definitely made for a few interesting
episodes but like
anytime bolo's name gets brought up i'm
like oh no yeah
to me like atlanta um is having like a
similar season but on a different scale
than like oc like because they just had
like limited time to foot
to film and like random trips they had
to take like oc got really [ __ ]
because like nothing happened and they
were like we're caught in the middle of
cobid
and atlanta i feel like they made the
best of like the coping situation but it
was not a great season
yeah i i totally agree but i feel like
it'll be a good reunion
yeah um and i wonder if drew and toyah
will be back because
toy's not even a housewife right now no
but that always happens she's like a
brandy glanville like how like someone
who's like a friend of
is the center of the entire yeah like
scandal
um i don't love toy i actually really
like drew she like really grew on me as
the season went on
and i think she's a really good
housewife except when
kenya said or toyah said like she needs
to stop worrying about my relationship
and get a relationship with the
treadmill like that was
so mean so wrong so wrong and like all
the other women laughing like that
really upset me because like when
when when cynthia and mike were in their
kitchen like trying to move the scale
around
like oh my god the scale was definitely
broken because they were like weighing
in more than they thought like
i was dying and like that's why i love
the housewives of atlanta because
they're so real and they both said their
weight
on camera on camera like you would
literally have to
like stone me to death before admitting
how much i weighed mm-hmm
but they were just like open and honest
so relatable like that's my year summed
up
yeah like moving the scale around like
in disbelief he's like no because like
the floor is on a decline like it was so
funny
and then that treadmill comment like
really bothered me yeah it was
it was wrong i didn't see that the i
didn't feel like the women were laughing
i felt like they were
made uncomfortable by it maybe also like
what is with kenya being the worst host
ever
like i love marlo for ordering like
pizza and wings but like she doesn't put
out a cheese plate for like
her five guests no it's it's really and
she thought they would be satiated with
wine but like
this group eats a lot like yeah they are
not satiated with just alcohol
no it's it's like funny i know because
also like in south carolina like it's a
pattern now
yeah i just love marlo like pharrell no
i i really like her
too and i just need everyone to like
forgive her for the dinner like it's
also at the end of the day they do
no no it's like horseshoe keep bringing
it up and at the end of the day like
she's going so
far out of her way like apologizing
apologizing but like what she did was
like she just acted out at dinner it's
not a huge deal it's not a huge deal
yeah she didn't hurt anyone right even
though next week it looks like things
get physical between drew and toyah yeah
and that was just like a
you know a ticking tie bomb yeah but i
also feel like
it's this weird um balance with like all
of the
existing housewives being like so
established and like been on forever and
like these two new girls like coming in
hurting themselves having to prove
themselves and it's like
two different shows by the way that's
it's like it's aunties and nieces like
no but like the not in terms of like
having fun but the way that like
troy and drew like are acting towards
one another it's like season because
it's season one for them
yeah it's like a season one but we're so
far past that we're so beyond silliness
like that
yeah yeah like because like and some of
the og's like
are a little boring like cynthia even
though i love her like she
is boring and even candy i the only
thing i really feel like candy's
integral towards is like
she has no alliances like she will
comment on a fight like not because she
sides with someone but just because
that's who she thinks is right like yeah
so she's actually like a good kind of
like narrator for the show because she's
very she's not like best friends with
anyone like she this is really just like
truly her job
she shows up and she like just comments
on what she shares her thoughts
yeah and i actually really respect that
because more often than not like in her
um
confessionals like i agree with her
because she's very unbiased
so i think she adds value in that but
some of the ogs are just like getting
like comfortable and like boring except
portia is literally just like the
funniest person on the show and like
everything she says is just like a
nugget of perfection like she was barely
in the episode last night because she
didn't get invited to kenya's but she
still somehow managed to be like
the queen of the episode yeah i just i
absolutely adore her
i think she's so funny um so yeah season
finale next week and then hopefully the
reunions will be good like you said
the worse the season the better reunion
true um
so i'm very much looking forward to that
there's nothing on tonight oh yay
so fabulous did you watch any other
stuff this weekend
uh i finished watching the last star on
netflix it was
really good like throughout there it was
definitely times i was bored and like
rasputin uh
but by the end like the way that it
ended and you know i'll just
if you guys are going to watch just me
me for a second because i want to spoil
it like it's not spoiled it's history
but it was so crazy because so basically
the tsar and his family
were brutally murdered at like during
the russian revolution they were like
buried in a forest no one
found them for like 50 years in the 70s
like some historians found them but like
the political climate like
it wasn't a good time to like tell
everyone so they stayed there for like
another 20 years
and then the bodies were exhumed and
they want they needed to prove that it
was the royal family because it was just
like bones and no one knew where they
had been buried
and so they got blood samples from all
of the royals throughout europe because
since they all like we're married
to one another they have similar dna and
even prince philip um
donated or gave jesus he is
old he gave blood to help in the cause
of proving that it was the royal family
oh that's interesting yeah it was really
interesting and then they had a proper
um imperial barrier right and
it was really interesting and i actually
watched something really similar
i liked the way that it was done because
it was like half documentary half
dramatized kind of like the college
admissions thing
yeah but it was really well done and and
if you're interested in a little bit of
history i would recommend it it also
deals with like this
question of like the anastasia imposter
um and there's like a lot of books on it
do you know this story and then
apparently i found out this story i
found out for the
taylor i found out okay so basically the
russian
royal family was murdered in like a
basement and there was a lot of mystery
around what happened
and some of the mystery that got out was
like that one of the daughters escaped
anastasia and so
eight years after the murder in berlin
a woman comes up and says i am anastasia
romanov and
that and i escaped blah blah blah and
spends this woman spent her entire life
saying i'm anastasia and like there are
so many people who are like no it's not
like the
grandma came in the tudor came i think
they just prove it like with blood it
was they didn't have that technology
for dna testing and she passed away
before it could be but
since her passing and they found the
bones of the imperial family
she is was not anastasia like her whole
life
oh i thought for sure she was good
apparently i was talking to kayla last
night and she just watched the movie
anastasia
and the disney movie anastasia is about
anesthesia romanov and apparently like
they say that
it's her but it wasn't her but it's like
a fiction cartoon no
no but like but raspy like there are a
lot of true elements
and they say that like she was the the
interesting remaining romanov but that's
not what happened
so and i think i need to watch anastasia
well really similarly i watched um
accepted
that movie with justin long and blake
lively and john hill and it's actually
like a [ __ ] great movie
it is except like you know like the
fatal flaw of the film
is justin long's character's name is
bartleby okay
and like he's like literally like the
center of the tv show and like
everyone's like hey bartleby hey b
like why was that his name that's just
it just like
it actually makes the movie like bad it
makes no [ __ ] sense
so that's what i was like spending my
whole weekend thinking about actually
didn't watch a lot of tv i spent most my
time on tech talk
oh well that explains that and then i
also i'm almost done with the book that
i'm reading called the queen's fortune
and it just took a turn it just got good
at 70
so i'll keep you guys impressed but it
is about
desiree clary who was the one-time love
of napoleon bonaparte and then married
his friend but her sister married his
brother
so she's part of the court quite
interesting but apparently she's going
to be queen of sweden
is she still alive no oh yeah no no like
in the
what's happening oh oh you're like she's
going to be the queen of sweden like
today
look on the next page oh okay so like
not tomorrow
okay okay like that was confusing the
way you phrased it
sorry yeah that tells me that 100
try to make me look stupid um so it
looks like the her
historical journey is like going really
well for you historical journey's going
really well i just like
i i sort of spread myself too thin and
watching last star while reading queen's
fortune because it's like then i had
this romanoff itch that i wanted to
scratch
and i was gonna hate when i have a
romanoff edge that i want to scratch and
like i just can't you know
yeah because i was in the middle of
another book so right but now i'm like
back in the napoleonic era so maybe i
don't know when i'm done with this book
and it was like a little disappointing
um i don't know where i'm going to go
from here i don't know do i go back to
the romanov so now you're back
back in the napoleonic era exactly happy
for you
um so yeah like that
was our show that was it was confirmed
it was ours confirmed we spoke about the
guys we spoke about the girls we pretty
much hit the nail on the head
yeah and it's confirmed that that's all
she wrote oh is it yeah
okay pens up what's the time's up
pencils up no what are they saying at
the end of sats like
pencils down
[Laughter]
thank you so much for listening to the
morning shows the millennial morning
show where we deliver the first five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts we found spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i got rid
of cats box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are if you made it to the end
of the episode thank you so much for
listening and we hope you have an
amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye
you